it was up to e3 2015 and the points
supposed to be going up tomorrow here so
god time busier we spent all day
yesterday checking out Kanye West who is
playing Uncharted in that room so we're
gonna rush this together we're gonna
talk about what the best things that
happened to e3 this year and hopefully
this little make sense at about five
minutes first of all though we're above
the West Hall here in the Attic CC and
this is the GameSpot war room which is
where we spend most of our time so oh
sorry lark GameSpot editors John and
bomb people kind of funnies over there
publish more videos Vinny let's find a
quiet spot to talk and hear hear kind of
funny hasn't gone laga
and okay so let's let's chew it out it
turns out a 2015 e3 and it all being
pretty great him also I kind of
go back was a couple of months ago I
didn't episode of that had 2015 was
gonna be a real stinker for video games
turns out a Nintendo Microsoft and
Bethesda had some to say about that so
that's our but Bethesda first of all
absolute the Barnstormer of a press
conference we always have these like who
won III things I was pretty sure that
the feds two had this whole thing
wrapped up turns out some other people
had as something to say about that what
would get to that and why for I
literally could not be happier they
showed off gameplay they showed off they
showed off the sort of the funny not
self serious tone that I think was
missing out of the trailers and they
showed all these different types of
mechanics like the fact that you're like
okay yeah sure you know you're in this
world and it's a super vivid and bright
and it looks great it's voice acting now
and oh yeah I guess why you can like
customize your like your your stuff and
then like oh you can actually build a
house I was like oh it's actually not a
house it's a it's a village and if to
provide people like I'm one stage I'm
thinking like are we is just rust or
like Daisy or something and they're like
oh yeah you could just be like any
weapons you want you know we're always
an iPhone game a spend most of the week
playing I can't stop everyone from dying
I think I've got up into like 20 people
max doom was there I talked to him was
I wasn't too hot on do I think I need to
play it to see more of that Waunakee
quake motto no that didn't stop me and
and they were super strong and then for
Microsoft Nintendo and Sony they all had
like strong features Microsoft first
thing they were really concentrating
home was 2015 and it turns out they've a
bunch of yeah video games coming in 2015
a lot of first party stuff which Sony
don't have so they had like Oh guess
what forces come in here's the four we
didn't see the HD version and I actually
think that the the gears for why are
they calling Greece were the gears for a
demo they did was one of the worst that
was in e3 but it's cool that that's
gonna be out next year or whatever say
beers coming at the Fords coming up and
they've had all five guardians coming
out and they showed a bunch of that that
looks really interesting I think it
actually might some of the Destiny
people here I think kind of what that
looks kind of cool and so I was curry
was good of them that they had games
coming out this year the Halal and stuff
worked really well and some of the guys
around here have used it and apparently
the demo they're actually shown here
with halo only has like a field of
vision that's a bit this big away from
your eyes so it doesn't look quite as
cool as it did on the stage but
apparently works and so that's cool and
I've been sewing for him what the
that's like we were up here in the
Warren this whole place was full of them
gamespot people watching the livestream
losing their goddamn minds
Adam boys skipped in here the next day
after her announcing three of the Most
Wanted games the people have been
screaming for fear so well this week
with not only we have fallout 4 we also
got at the Last Guardian immediately
we got Final Fantasy 7 HD it's like a
full remake and and then on top of that
a Shenmue kick starter which as of now
is probably around the 4-minute mark and
hopefully sony will are likely there
well they are they're putting some money
into our project as well we don't really
know how much but it's gonna be
interesting because the I think and
adjusted for inflation the budget of
Shenmue 2 is about 50 million bucks or
68 maybe yeah so that was that was crazy
but the one thing about Sony's
conference that kind of once I slept on
it was oh wait no nothing's coming here
this year these are all future 2016 2017
or in the case of Final Fantasy Shenmue
like probably 2020 like years of way in
the future so that's kind of a problem
for Sony and the other thing is that if
you show off Morpheus and are hearing
some sort of whispers are in the show
floor is that they actually had planned
to show a lot of
morpheus so and it was it was kind of
what we're hearing is it was kind of
pull last minute in the way that we also
heard last year that last Guardian in
the pulled last minute whether or not
that it's true don't know apparently
Microsoft had problems with hololens up
until at the end of last week for their
demo maybe there was some technical
problems for Sony I guess we'll find out
soon enough
hopefully they'll show some stuff at
Gamescom more throughout the rest of the
year but really yeah it's I think it's
important for them to get Morpheus out
there in front of more people and
Nintendo had an interesting week again
they don't really do the one big
conference anymore they had their their
world championships on Sunday that the
tree has running all week and then they
had the kind of a decent-enough
press conference in the morning a
partial Metroid Prime stuff I don't
think that games ever going it I don't
know I can't see it I'll do that apart
from that the one good thing that they
also displayed was the same thing
Microsoft did which is hey guess what
there's a bunch of video games coming in
this year on the Wii U so we've got
starfox
they got Mario Tennis I'm like a massive
fan of Mario Tennis games
I wish they'd make another Mario at
golfing and strikers charge I'll be
happy enough lieutenant my maker is also
coming up andthat's had a really good
showing at the Nintendo World
Championships so there's a lot of good
games coming out this year it's crazy to
think and then in terms of actually
playing games like I spend most of my
time on the show floor interviewing
people I get the games come to me which
is I'm super super nice and fortunate I
usually get to play one game a year this
year I run it into the South Hall I take
TrackMania turbo with it gets cold it
looks pretty great I'm a TrackMania fan
it looks fun looks like trackmania
Nations works on a ps4
ManiaPlanet Smosh involved apparently so
it's pretty cool and then the other
thing I had to play at was no man's sky
we went over and talked to Sean we shot
a little video thing will will maybe put
it to maybe later we'll figure it out it
and but I actually got to play no-one's
guy actually have to see it and and that
is a video game found a planet and then
I handed on duty controls and he killed
everything and and it was cool and I
will talk about it a bit more and I
think over the next couple weeks of
months I'm interested to see when
they're gonna be nice to release date
because there was very much a feeling
when I was talking to Sean that they
kind of wish that they could I think
they don't wanna put themselves under
too much pressure with that and I think
from playing us the the scale of the
game I think sort of changed for me it's
definitely a massive
a huge vast universe when you're flying
through the map and trying to find a
star to land on it's it's it's that
gives you that feeling that like you
know looking up Carl Sagan videos at
2:00 a.m. while you're having a beer
make you feel super insignificant it
gives you a kind of feeling and but when
you're playing it kind of it feels like
a sort of intergalactic Minecraft
because you're you're collecting
resources and you're getting getting
currency units and then you go to a
spaceship and you're like you're
upgrading yourself you're getting a ship
and your guns and your weapons and those
mechanisms are super detailed and like
allow for a lot of that customization
and but because there's no like grand
story it's all sort of implied what
they're teaching you it feels like
you're sort of I think it'll be like the
early days of Minecraft where over the
weeks of when it's actually launched and
when people start to play it what that
game is will be found out so I think
it's really cool that what they're doing
is it's just stepping back not getting
too specific on the mechanisms and just
saying look when this games out there
you can go play us and then we'll see if
people like it and we'll see what sort
of stories come out of it and one story
that I have that of it was that when you
died I knew like a quote pops up kind of
like Call of Duty one where it's like
you know war quotes pop up you know say
you know famous figures around that era
and so like we saw Carl Sagan quote pop
up on the Sony conference right at the
end so it loads of these of like
philosophers and astrophysicists and all
this like all these the quotes pop up
and but they've also got tweets from
Jaden Smith and here's well so
apparently if you die enough times it'll
just like surface one of Jaden Smith's
very super a philosophical tweets like
if how can mirrors exist if eyes don't
exist finally this is them recognizing
that maybe all this is a little bit
pretentious this game it's supposed to
be fun and so they've thrown some little
bit of nonsense in there as well it's
been a really fun III thank you very
much for watching all the stuff on
GameSpot as it turns out 2015 is
actually approaching like 2004 and 1998
levels of video game releases we've
still got Metal Gear Solid coming out
and with The Witcher guys are prancing
around here delighted with hair came
that came in earlier dear and take
blood-borne like just all these great
games that came out and Nintendo and
Microsoft and Bethesda really put
forward their stakes as well stuff from
square and EA as well but really I have
go onto a youtube stage in a second
Andy's got to edit this so we're out
thank you very much for watching this
episode of the point move back in two
weeks
adios
you